oui un potentiel explosif c'est un
leader charismatique c'était un leader
qui a choisi des angles d'attaqué
pertinents qui peuvent porter il ya la
question de la corruption qui était
évoqué la question également du
nationalisme russe
navalni par exemple ne s'est pas opposé
à un ex-candidat crime et il faut le
savoir
navalni 7 quelqu'un qui dénonce c'est
quelque part un un populiste c'est
quelqu'un qui est jusqu'à présent en
tout cas n'a pas proposé d'alternative
d'où la limite de son exercice
mais encore une fois je ne crois pas que
contrairement à ce qui a pu être dit
poutine aient peur et n'avait ni le
pouvoir ait peur de navalni parce qu'il
ne représente pas une menace immédiate
en revanche ce qui perturbe le système
ce à quoi le système n'est pas habitué
c'est que navalni n'a pas peur de
poutine et d'ukraine ça c'est quelque
chose qui les désarçonne et si on ajoute
évidemment l'utilisation des nouvelles
technologies des réseaux sociaux
le fait que navalni ses partisans
feuilles tonnes l'année révélation tout
cela aboutit à une situation dans
laquelle le pouvoir est en retard il
réagi un scénario qu'il ne maîtrise pas
or la hantise plutôt à l'obsession du
pouvoir russe et la maîtrise des choses
et là il
il ne maîtrise pas le calendrier ne
maîtrise pas l'ensemble des facteurs
[Musique]